alright it looks like we are now live
for the January 2018 and what's at 17
ask me anything session and I think I
have earned out some of the kinks got
some a little bit better lighting
because I'm sitting in my wife's chair
instead of over there in my my own chair
sunlight isn't going to be quite so
crazy move this back just a little bit
so I can yeah there we go
that's a bit better so let's see we've
got 8 viewers already I'm gonna wait
just a minute and see who comes in and
also go over and check you know I've got
to do two things at once when it comes
to this the way that YouTube is set it
up looks like they have the live chat
alright people are logging in with it
and I guess these are questions that
people already left ahead of time so I
may as well get started with them one of
them I think is pretty easy to to
address has to do a stoicism and it's
from the old cui Ora 44 it's kind of an
interesting question
and actually the random guy just has a
follow-up on that
so the Stoics said we should live
according to our nature do they believe
living according to our nature would
help us live in harmony with the
universal reason yep they sure did and
this is something that I'm currently I
think I may have mentioned before I'm
currently writing a book on it's going
rather slowly because I've got other
book projects going on but what are the
Stoics actually mean by nature and here
is sort of a thumbnail sketch of that
with precipitous there's there's a
distinction that you know we got nature
let's call it capital end which means
the totality of the universe right
distinctive lis human nature and to live
in accordance with nature means both
according to cruciferous and the rest of
the Stoics
and I think that's there in xenos
thought I mean that's that's underlying
the Stoics who we have like see it very
clearly in a rally is in epictetus and
in Seneca and you know in the other bits
of stoic stuff that that we've got so
random guys question furthermore what
are the Stoics mean by living according
to our nature they don't mean at the
cynic sense they do mean a kind of in
the cynic sense they just think that the
cynics it means you see Epictetus
talking about this they think that some
of the cynics you know a demand a way of
life that's very difficult for most
people to actually follow some of the
Stoics actually we're a bit more hostile
to the cynics and said you know
including some of the people who are
attracted to stoicism of work the Stoics
like cicero and they were like listen
those cynics they like break convention
for the sake of doing that they they
talk about like you know being natural
that way but it's really it's kind of
just being a jerk rather than actually
being natural and I think there was you
know if we look at the satires
like in Lucien there was there a good
number of cynics who who are basically
people who just want to flout their nose
at convention so I think that that's a
good way to look at living in accordance
with nature in the contrast between
stoicism and cynicism living in
accordance with nature means living in
accordance with our human nature which
means a developing and developed human
nature and being in accordance with the
order of things you know not demanding
things to be radically different than
and how they they actually are so what
else let's let's take Michaels question
here does for conceptual content
translate into that which inhabits the
unconscious does Diet psychotherapy two
and one into the four concepts of the
collective unconscious as opposed to the
personal unconscious to do theirs
intersect Heidegger and Jung I don't
know there's not something I've actually
thought much about I would say that the
psychotherapy
psychotherapy as opposed to say
cognitive psychotherapy or you know
behaviorist psychotherapy are out there
different approaches if we're talking
about that that depth psychology stuff
that you know Freud young people like
that are associated with you know are we
using it to figure out the four concepts
of the things that we bring to the table
the the collective or the personal
unconscious it makes sense I don't know
that you know that it's that easy to
combine and Heidegger and and you know
sort of Freudian or psychoanalytic
tradition I would say you know it's
really important with Heidegger to not
try to take one concept and strip it
away from all the other concepts because
you know pre understanding is is it's
one of the four equi primordial right
and so it's connected with mood it's
connected with discourse or or speech or
however you want to translate Veda
it's also connected with Ronis that's
that's me I'm kind of a you know purist
in that way
a lot of questions already so I better
get get on it Zack asks taking a Hegel
seminar oh it's not asking taking a
nickel seminar this semester and your
antha or Hegel videos have been
incredibly useful thank you for making
that's great to hear that's that's the
purpose of them glad that you found them
helpful you know it's a lot of work goes
into them more work than I originally
expected it to be I think I thought by
this time I would be finished with the
whole series and I'm still deep in the
heart of spirit but you know I think we
charted it out maybe another maybe less
than two years to go I think we have and
I'm hoping that they will be a resource
for decades to come with with Hegel you
don't they can do it
all apart that's why like I'm a half our
Eagle site if you go to it you know the
heifer Hegel blog and you look on the
video thing I've got it broken down
according to section which YouTube
doesn't do in the playlist but it's
really nice like if you're like well I
don't want to wade through this gigantic
playlist which now has two hundred plus
videos to try to find stuff on
skepticism you can actually like jump to
that that section so I think that's kind
of nice um here's a more personal
question from moreover you always said
you were a big man but just how many
feet are you vertically so I'm six foot
three which i think is about two meters
for the the rest of the world that
doesn't use the in the old english
system call it the imperial system the
thing that we're wedded to here in the
United States yeah III and I was this
tall when I was twelve years old so I I
am a big man not only in the sense of
being tall and being broad but also you
know I weigh more than I should but when
I was 13 years old I was this tall and
only you know I think like when I when I
got to high school so I was 14 I was 140
pounds and this tall so I was so skinny
then I would actually leave shirts
because I didn't want anyone to see how
skinny my arms were and then I started
working out I guess then I got bigger
hermod has a really interesting question
here have you ever found the study of
philosophy born and there have been two
reasons for that one is I think there
are treatments of philosophy also
thinker is within the field of
philosophy who do manage to make
philosophy boring and so you know you
read them and you're like oh I
understand what they're up to but this
is just mine numbing why am I wasting my
time on this and and quite frankly a lot
of
philosophy these days that you see in
journals and even in quite a few books
is like that you know you're like what
is the point you know I get what they're
up to because you know they laid
everything out very clearly in the
introduction chapter one will be about
this this is for a very very small group
that are interested in this particular
ism and these particular articles I
think that that's kind of more you know
I'm not saying that everything should
always be immediately applicable to our
lives or stuff like that but but you
know a big thick book a lot to captivate
us I mean it might challenge us and
require a lot of work paintings
phenomenology spirit or one thing but
you know it should offer us something
that that really interests us and that's
that's what I've gravitated towards and
I think that's part of why I do last
stuff on contemporary and more stuff on
classical philosophy the other thing is
I can say that you know there have been
periods of my life where I've been
preoccupied with my own problems or
issues you know sometimes been in a fog
worried about finances scrambling to you
know do a whole bunch of different
classes and then you know there's
there's not the and the leisure of
thought and I don't think you're
required awful lot but I want to give to
be independently wealthy or anything
like that when some of the ancient
Greeks portrayed it to do philosophy
well but you do have to be able to have
some measure of space in order to relax
enough to take on you know philosophical
thinking and so sometimes that hasn't
been the case for me you know when I'm
overextended myself with projects and
clients you know can get get boring and
you know I think that's that's okay it
does it's not the end of the world if
that happens so for those who have had
that happen to them you know don't beat
yourself up about it just try to do what
you need to do to get out of the funk
all right James asks about Brothers
Karamazov
which I have to admit I haven't read for
years and the brothers karamazov
represent an aspect of humanity yeah I'd
say I say you know more broadly every
character in a Dostoevsky novel
represents some kind an aspect of
humanity and you know could be like
somebody just wound up that way whether
that's the story that they tell
themselves or they chose to issue eight
this aspect I'm blanking a little bit on
on what's Merida cough was was actually
like I can't remember him as being kind
of a craven figure but I don't speculate
about that all right
oh here's kind of a silly question Scott
Hall would Plato root for Patriots or
Vikings good for either of them I don't
think either represents some sort of you
know important
athos or anything along those lines I
mean I know I won't root for them myself
because I'm sick of seeing the Patriots
win year after year after year that gets
kind of boring you know I'm a Packers
fan so obviously I'm not going to root
for the Vikings I'm a weird Packers fan
too I'm a Packers fan who's also a Bears
fan I know that's gonna be anathema to
some people but my family's from to the
Chicago region on my mother's side well
I my adopted father's side and my my
biological grandfather side too so you
know I grew up like liking both the
Bears of the Packers and and that
continued when they play against each
other out of course I root for the
Packers cuz I'm a good Wisconsin ight
but so that means I reserve my
irrational hatred for the Vikings and
you know a little bit for the Lions but
the Lions don't matter quite so much so
shrim probably pissing some people on
saying that all right back to serious
philosophy questions the elk we are 44
did Zeus give us the Faculty of choice
that we can no longer suffer
that essentially what stoic strive to do
to be free from suffering good question
yeah I would say that the Stoics think
that insofar as we're suffering some
things are still out of whack that
doesn't mean that we don't have
emotional responses and and those
emotional responses can include some
things that we do consider negative
emotion so you get a rational fear
that's what they call caution in LA baya
one of the you Polly
right the the good emotional response is
you can you know and this is where like
there's some distinction between like
say Cicero and Seneca on one side and
you know we might say more orthodox
Stoics on the other there of grief you
know should you feel grief when when
somebody dies you know there's a sir
maybe a rational way to do that you know
a certain a certain amount of of
grieving but not like pulling your hair
out or you know staying in mourning for
years and years and years but yeah in in
so far as we're using our Faculty of
choice rightly which means we're using
it to modify the Faculty of choice this
part what it means to have freedom it's
not just freedom to choose between
different options it's freedom to choose
about where one is going and that
involves kind of that's available to
rational beings according to the Stoics
yeah the one of the goals is to to like
get yourself out of suffering when you
don't need to be suffering Tom writes
you should turn on super chat so we can
give you some dollars for questions yeah
I looked at super chat and I may do it
later on down the line but I'm always
like a little bit behind in getting
things done so I haven't gotten around
to it what I will do here though is I'll
put in and we'll see if it shows up
because I'm gonna put it in the chat
thing in the screen that I have where I
don't see everybody else's things I will
see if it pops up in the the the other
one because YouTube's kind of funny that
way
so I don't say if you want to support my
my work which includes doing this sort
of thing but also you know creating the
videos editing Stoicism today doing
other kinds of work blogging all that
then patreon I think is is one of the
ways to go because it's you know easy it
affords a regular income I know some
people are kind of ticked off about it
collecting value-added taxes or
censoring certain people but I you know
that's that's not really my my thing
let's see if it showed up it doesn't
look like it did so I'm gonna I'll paste
it down down here as well well I don't
know if I can actually I just can't
myself that's weird
hmm yeah like I said the interface is a
little bit wonky I'm not not the biggest
fan of this this format I'm sure there's
got to be a way to do it a little bit
better yeah
anyway let's uh let's just talk about
God should oh here is how I can get into
the say something there post uh still
not able to get in there to post it I
don't know what's wrong with this page
there we go alright okay back to
questions because it looks like there's
a lot of them here ah pink levan why do
you dislike Reggie nogueira GUI
lagrangean so this is very abstruse sort
of you know intra Catholic topic what is
your opinion on the revival of neo
scholasticism in recent years
particularly or Danberg confessor
irregular gulag Raj I don't like in park
as he was he was a bad scholar he's got
some good works you know but he was in
many respects you know he went after
blown dal and other people without
actually understanding their works so he
definitely showed a lack of you know the
principle of charity that's supposed to
be
motivating our work as scholars and and
I don't like people who are super into
gara garage because that's all they read
and so they don't read across you know
sort of the spectrum of 20th century
Catholic thought and see what everybody
else had to say about things they're
just like I've got this guy and he's I
mean they essentially they adopt a sort
of superstitious attitude towards Gary
gula garage he doesn't represent the
spectrum of neo scholasticism he
represents this little sliver of it the
aligning very well with people's you
know sort of need for a kind of
constricted order same thing that you
know I mean he's not read nowadays but
you know Pedro de corpus was another guy
like that very schematic and it appeals
to a certain kind of mentality um I
don't really care about fessor I don't
know Oldenburg there are so many people
doing interesting work taking the
thought of Thomas Aquinas or other
medieval 's that you know I focus on
that so you know I'm interested I mean
I'm more interested at the same what
else there McIntyre is doing then and
what fessor is doing or you know anybody
who's like in the line of gurgle garage
there's so much great stuff out there
that there's there's not enough time for
me to spend on that
and I let other people fight those
battles for me so yeah and like I said I
don't get enough time to read primary
texts anyway a tripping fool have you
ever considered lecturing on crew stacks
so here I have to make kind of a
confession that I think could cause some
people to like you know think that I'm
I'm not a very good guy
I don't like first I read you know
around in his works when I was doing the
you know like reading my way through
French literature thing and I just I did
not find him interesting I also not into
James Joyce you know for me that that
sort of you know super you know turned
in on itself analysis of things again
what they were doing but I just I don't
I don't find it worth my time
I'm more interested in in other stuff
unfortunately so there's no way I could
lecture I'm Proust because I'm not you
know a competent to do that sort of
thing
Jonathan Conroy has a good question here
do you think Western civilization
civilization is in crisis
whatever my views on catastrophic
climate change if any how might stoicism
help us to deal with these an emergency
situation so great set of questions do I
think Western civilization is in crisis
not really I mean Western civilization
is one of those buzzwords that means a
hundred different things right if we're
talking about like the study of the
humanities or something like that it's
always been in crisis that's been in
crisis for the last couple hundred years
you know both people on the left and the
right have been guarding that constantly
and people in the center I mean what are
we actually talking about with Western
civilization like are we worried that
you know in geopolitical terms that say
the Islamic world or that you know the
Chinese or somebody like that their
culture is going to swamp us you know
sort of a Michael Harrington clash of
civilizations thing I mean that could
happen but you know there's enough
interesting stuff and then we can
compare between Chinese and and Western
things to have some great you know
points of discussion so you know I don't
really think I don't think Western
civilization is in crisis but Western
civilization is always kind of a a work
in progress anyway what are my thoughts
on catastrophic climate change well I
think that we're undergoing it I know
that there's lots of debate about you
know what does the science say and all
that sort of stuff
fine you can find some scientists that
is people who are trained in science
that are doing science who say that it's
not happening and by that they don't
mean you know that
they mean usually that it's not man-made
you know climate change I think that the
verdict is in that that you know it is
we are undergoing it the question is are
we going to have any political will to
do anything about it as a species before
we really screw up the environment
beside having grown up here in Wisconsin
you can look outside look at the amount
of snow that we have look at how warm it
is in general even when it does get cold
and you can tell things have changed you
can see that species that didn't live
here are now you know invading you can
see again how you know blackberries are
crowding out black raspberries if you go
a little bit further south to here oh I
think that I mean and when it comes down
to it the the entities that that you
know dam 'pl the Pentagon they're
concerned about climate change and it's
instability that it that it's causing so
you know it's something that's a weird
thing that people are like devoted
irrationally to thinking that it doesn't
exist we should just get over it right
and then the left and the right can
fight well how should we actually
respond to it but but there shouldn't be
any question that we need to respond to
it and I hope I hope we do you know so
stoicism how would stoicism help us with
this sort of thing well you know to
begin with you focus if you're doing
stoic philosophy you focus on yourself
everybody else's business and worrying
about how everybody else should behave
look at yourself and see what a mess you
are and start to work on some of that it
doesn't mean like you disassociate so I
don't care about anything outside of
myself because you know you do care
about things outside of yours also let's
not kid ourselves as you probably should
care about because justice is in fact
one of the virtues and so is wisdom and
that does connect us together in in a
kind of you know cosmopolitan community
but you know you really have to work on
yourself so like if you wanted to get
involved in activism I mean you'd have
to do sort of the thing that Martin
Luther King and his followers did
you know and they're prepping for these
marches if you get anger problems you
don't get to March you have to sit out
of the March because you're gonna cause
more problems you you have to develop
the the resiliency to be able to take
take steps and so I think that's that's
kind of kind of good here's a really
interesting question from Christian what
authors are books from contemporary
philosophy do you think will go down in
history so who is gonna be read a
hundred years from now 200 years from
now and not just simply I mean read
bye-bye
you know people doing a dissertation if
people will actually talk about them I
think Alistair McIntyre is gonna be
somebody who people are gonna be saying
is of major importance
who else who's currently alive would I
say I mean there's like a whole bunch of
people involved in the what we can call
the you know the virtue ethics I don't
want to stay revival because that that
you know that plays into this this
history that's been told about law
virtue ethics was gone and then you know
got resuscitated with Alice Ambrose and
and these people in England there's no
it hadn't been gone it was just it
wasn't being taught in the Academy in
english-speaking places plenty of people
talking about it and you know the
french-speaking world or the German
world because you know authors are doing
it and plenty of people in history of
philosophy but you know if you think
about contemporary virtue ethics so you
know there's there's quite a few
interesting thinkers that therefore the
body of work right Martha Nussbaum would
be one but I'm actually much more
partial to Julia honest I really like
her work you know who else is going to
be I don't know there's a lot of really
interesting contemporary philosophers
but it's hard to predict who's gonna
have that staying power
Jade to be to Nick I'm not sure what
that's supposed to represent thank you
so much for these AMAs previously you
talked about how the Eastern Orthodox
theologians Miss misrepresented us
understand st. Anselm and their
critiques can you elaborate on that I
mean it basically amounts to sort of
tendentious readings and it comes from
the fact that Ansem represented the
Western position and in the Council of
Bari right so he kind of got on their
their radar about that but a lot of you
know it's it's attentive reading and and
David Bentley hard I think it's been
really good in exposing this from the
Orthodox side in a piece he did a 15 20
years ago really what it what it depends
on is is a a theory about what the
Incarnation was about and the the
Orthodox portray and some as having this
very Penal II oriented you know that is
punishment oriented theory and it's
actually not there and an attentive
reading of cur Deus homo in his works
but you know you can read anybody and
get something out or just like people
can read Hume and get the is a lot
distinction and and not you know of
course if you you discover that he's not
so concerned about what what modern you
know the modern people have turned into
he's just concerned to show that we
always have some blocks in the
background right and so let's let's make
those Lots clear and so there's lots of
that sort of thing in the history of
philosophy
Kyle philosophy has mental masturbation
discuss um think that that could fit the
way some people do philosophy but I told
little time with people who do that sort
of stuff that I don't know what I would
stay other than they're kind of wasting
their time
clearly it's much more than that and
that's really all that needs to be said
um Peter rates which author apart from
Heidegger wrote on the concept of
ilithyia
well I mean people used that term I like
they uh you know throughout history
because it just it means truth right who
has a sort of high daguerreian concept
of truth is all Isaiah that's a good
question I mean I don't think that that
really got a hell of a lot of traction
outside of that I actually have a client
who I'm reading gabriela Marcel's
mystery of being with is different
lectures we just went over the chapter
on truth and Marcel was saying I don't
know about Heidegger's a discussion of
the essence of truth and he's got some
ideas of his own
yeah there's some similarities there in
Marcel even though he's not endorsing
but the term and I think you know lot to
be pulled out I think most people sort
of just stop once that all truth is all
that's really cool and they don't ask
well what sort of modes of are being
given by different kinds of bas so Andre
asks can you recall any philosophical
works about pain in its various forms
that you found interesting pain in its
various forms I mean I don't know any
specifically just about pain there's
some great discussions I mean if you've
never read variant theory then you
should be if you're interested in ethics
even if you're not even to latarian you
should read Bentham's introduction to
the principles of morals and legislation
he's got other works too that are kind
of cool but Bentham was like very
exhaustive and trying to different kinds
of pleasures and all the different kinds
of pain and how he would analyze them
that's kind of a cool thing to check out
I think he actually created something
almost like a chart at one point to that
I might have in a PDF form somewhere
random guy what do you think of Jordan B
Peterson and would you like to speak to
him do you
plan to go through his new book I don't
have any plans to get his new book but
it's not because I have anything against
him it's just because I don't have a lot
of time I mean if somebody wants to send
it to me then I'll take a look at it but
I actually have a stack you know of
about 15 20 books that I'm supposed to
review for the Sadler's honest book
reviews and I'm a little bit behind on
that I know Peterson is is interesting
you know kind of you know I I think this
is one of the dangers right when you
become a public figure one reason why
you know he's got way way more followers
and people doing similar things have way
more followers and viewers and all that
because they're saying a very simple
coherent message that can be you know is
it's got clear good guys and bad guys
and stuff like that whereas you know if
you bring up you know what do you think
about Renee Tia Kurt wow there's a good
side there's a bad side you see a
modernist you mean by modernist right so
if you have nuance in that sense than
people sometimes just kind of tune out
because I think a lot of people go to
public figures in intellectual life not
because they want that sort of you know
deeper delve into things what are the
concepts doing here right they they want
you know a nice story to tell and so I
think Peterson kind of allowed himself
to get get drawn off in that direction
and now he's you know he's a figure of
the right against the left against what
he calls post-modernism I I have a real
problem with you know throwing that term
around because there's a bunch of
different post-modernism 's you don't
want to lock them all under one one
thing and you know what I talk with I'm
sure yeah I mean I'll talk with most
people I go on quite a few podcasts and
shows and stuff like that but you know
the question is would he be interested
in talking with me and I don't know if
you would you know that would be
something you'd have to ask him
uh trial right speaking of Hegel in your
view what a Marxist tend to get wrong
about Hegel I'm speaking as someone who
studied Marxism in depth
I mean I think the reduction to you know
the Kigali and three step of you know
thesis antithesis synthesis when we look
at Hegel's works now some of them do
have some of them are very schematic
that way but a lot of them art and you
know depends on what kind of Marxist
we're talking about you know a lot of a
lot of the humanist Marxists go back to
Hegel and bring Hegel back into marks
because Marx was a Hegelian after all
and in this whole stream very
interesting people arguing back and
forth about what hey Galleon is amines
and how it would play out and I think
that they take a lot of stuff back in
from Hegel what else I mean the notion
so Marx and Hegel share one thing
particularly in common which is this
emphasis on the practical that ideas
have to be in some respect respects it's
kind of similar to the movement that we
call pragmatism in American philosophy
saying that okay what is what is the the
idea really amount to when you put it
into practice right I think there's
there's that and then you know so
portraying Hegel as being somebody who
was interested in understanding the
world without without changing it I
don't think it's quite true but that's
probably enough on that let's see have
you encountered any self-professed
needless in academia and what is your
opinion on Neel ISM is it a disease
soneul ism is one of those terms it
means different things to alright there
were the movement of me lists and in
Czarist Russia that's not quite the same
thing is what nature calls Niall is 'm
although Nietzsche is somebody who is
reading Russian literature
and I think that there's a lot of people
these days who use the word media list
and they basically just mean that data
they don't then recognize any moral
standards or you know standards of truth
and they're gonna do what the hell they
want right and third view on it they're
not I mean the Neela's and Russia were
kind of politically committed to
changing society but they they
recognized that there was no like
absolute grounding for that liberals in
that way yeah I've had some people who
claim that their NIA lists but I've
never met one who was very consistent
with it because you know suddenly they'd
be in a relationship and now they have
all sorts of beliefs about how they
ought to be right or they you know they
want a loan from you so that they can
get some more beer and suddenly you know
they they they you know appeal to
principles or things like that so I
don't know there's there's not many
people who can really live it out that
effectively like I kind of like
Nietzsche's idea of nihilism which is
this you know he doesn't construe it as
like a consistent stance it's it's
something that kind of shifts from bit
to bit and the person who is in the a
list isn't necessarily fully aware of
what they're doing or a process or a
institution that's nihilistic
doesn't really understand that it's
devalued the highest value that's sort
of suck the guts out of everything is it
as a disease it can become one and you
know I think in it why is it being a
problem more in some some areas than
others Oh Victor what are your three
favorite non philosophy books my three
favourite so that's that's a good
question so I have this this copy of
Bernays labyrinths and that use
I would say my hands-down favorite one
but I recently got like the collected
fiction of Boris that has those stories
and more in it although translated by
different translator and I'd say that
one now is my my favorite I bet you know
I'd have to say one of Phillip K dicks
books would be my second favorite but
then I'd have to pick is it you know
there's some really great ones you know
flow my tears the policeman said Scanner
Darkly is really be my favorite one
although a man in the high castle - I
really like as well so more Hays dick
and then I mean who would I pick is my
my third favorite I would you know it
for for a while but I really I'm a big
fan of Graham Greene and I'm looking
forward to going back to when his early
novels bright and rock I've always
wanted to do like a video about that to
talk about about that you know as a
matter of time the literature so alright
Christopher what do you think about an
interdisciplinary humanities PhD I'm
looking at graduate schools and Brock
University as a master's in philosophy
but they have a PhD and
interdisciplinary humanities I think it
really depends totally on what you want
to do with it there's two things -
there's there's there's at what you want
to do with it you want to make sure you
know if you're not independently wealthy
or if you you know if you're not a
person who doesn't care about earning an
income at all then if you're going into
a degree program you want to see what is
their placement what kind of jobs can
you actually find are you thinking about
an academic track which is kind of a
dismal prospect these days or are you
try to figure out how you might like
turn it into something else that you
could do you know because there's lots
of ways to do thinking and philosophy
outside of the Academy and some I think
some programs are smarter at that and
other programs like they you know they
think that's failing if you don't do
that so there's that and then you will
look at the specifics of the program
who are you getting to study with what
courses do they offer or what do people
who've been in the program say about it
like five years down the line that that
I think would be important so it's not
as if you can just decide only about an
interdisciplinary program you want to
think about what about this particular
one I think that's that's important a
good question here from the elk we Ora
what sort of exercises would you
recommend to help hone the virtue
justice
I still struggle not getting annoyed
with people and so I'm looking for extra
size to help combat that so it's less
about justice and I think more about
irritation and annoyance right I mean
how did Aristotle says how do you become
just by doing just actions and doing
them the way that just person does them
so not just doing just actions to avoid
punishment or because you get a cookie
at the end or because you know you you
want to impress this this girl or this
guy who's watching you or something like
that you'd like to date but but doing it
because you recognize the intrinsic
value of there's there's that and and so
are there exercises yeah I mean you
could you could think very practically
about like you know where do you want to
commit yourself right somebody has to do
with like thinking things out too you
know it was a great example of
Epictetus but it has to do with envy but
it has to do with envy over like the
fairness of the world so he says to do
this all the time because I found myself
feeling Envy sometimes and colleagues or
other people they like I came up with
who seem to be doing much better and
getting a lot more opportunities
Epictetus says does that person get like
an advancement or an opportunity or you
know a position or something like that
well good for them if it's a good thing
then you can be happy that they got it
you know and if it's not really that
important then why are you allowing
yourself to get envious over that right
I think that can be helpful if you
struggle with that sort of thing you're
talking more about like how do you deal
with irritation or anger perhaps even
righteous in
nation so I think that you know one of
the things that both the aristotelian
and stoic and he also the the Platonic
not not so much in Plato but like in
Plutarch traditions do do is we needed
to analyze the sort of system of
thoughts that are churning through our
head
sometimes we vocalize them and sometimes
we don't like sometimes we mutter them
under our breath dance I'm a [ __ ] you
know I don't know why you know he cut me
off
he's always doing right we do this and
so when we put them out there and we can
actually act Racal reasoning that's
going on that really helps right we can
you know that doesn't it's not a
guaranteed win but when we put it out
there we can be like oh that's kind of
irrational that thing that I'm thinking
there you know and so I think that can
help now there's a number of other
things that that we can do Majah thanks
for the conversation so either basket
basketball player or a philosopher you
know I didn't do basketball well when I
was a kid in part because I didn't
realize that I needed these glasses and
if you look at mine you notice one eye
is much thicker than the other as my
right eye is pretty bad like that screen
is already blurry to me right there
whereas the left eye is pretty clear and
so like a lot of things medically I mean
I didn't realize that my ankles over
pronated until my mom's boyfriend at the
time is like man when your kid runs he
makes a lot of noise with his feet I
think you should take him to a
podiatrist there were a lot of things
like that growing up in the 70s and 80s
where we didn't we didn't realize that
you know we needed two things and I
didn't know I needed glasses for a while
I just thought the world look look so so
I need a hell of a time doing basketball
and doing baseball because that you know
depth perception being able to see where
things are coming I was great when it
came to like dribbling and doing layups
or stealing the ball from people and
defending but doing long shot that's a
trouble and I had trouble with baseball
at gauging exactly where the ball was
coming
football was fine because you know I
played when I when I played I was
generally a linebacker so I had tackled
people and when I was playing soccer
which I loved I was always a defender
you know I specialized and taking the
ball away from people and sometimes
knocking him down so you don't need a
lot of site for that right so yeah so
anyway no no bass low basketball playing
random guy I have bad
ADHD in him even harder time pushing
through philosophy Texas I otherwise
would have what solution should I should
I employ to resolve this for failing
that what tech should i prioritize um
that's a great question so I mean I
would take bits at a time you know you
you you know you don't have to do it
there's nothing that says you have to do
all of them at once and and you know
some of them are probably going to be a
bit harder to concentrate on I mean
Hegel I have a hell of a time then
there's some times when I go up I'm
pointing up because that's where I do
the shooting up there and I've got the
book and I've been thinking about it and
I've got stuff on the chalkboard I'm
like yeah I don't know what the hell I'm
doing me I lost the the train of thought
I can't shoot right now you know there
are days like that that happens with
some other philosophers to that I like
Heidegger Heidegger stuff Cicero I can
almost always shoot on Cicero cuz they
be they're good Aristotle you know but
others can be more difficult so I don't
beat yourself up about it just do what
you can do you know uh you know you
might find that there's certain
philosophers who you enjoy more reading
like I really enjoyed reading to cart
maybe maybe do that Christopher what
books would you recommend to someone
interested in the idea of progress aside
from the phenomenology of spirit well
you know the phenomenology of spirit
doesn't really tell us that much about
like progress itself it just sort of
lays out what Hegel takes to be the
progress of the consciousness
um Mills writings I think are kind of
important
you know the whole pragmatist tradition
you know James Royce Dewey
maybe purse
you know the enlightenment philosophers
who are trying to think about things
moving ahead you can even like to read
the people who don't like progress like
the traditionalists I mean that way
somebody will actually read them because
very few people do but I don't mean the
traditionalists that people bring up
these days like a bowl are people like
that I mean like the actual people who
called themselves traditionalists back
in the nineteenth century saw the French
Revolution was a big problem and we're
trying to turn things back like to bone
hauled and demise and and people like
that who I even read through years but
but or a mom and a - it would be an
example of that
ah je Blucher will you ever do a series
or video on thus spake Zarathustra yes I
do intend to i'm the existentialism
series again it's gonna take some time
before I can actually get to and that
book will definitely be in there because
it's pretty important pair old buys
that's you own thoughts on Maimonides
interesting thinker not somebody I do a
lot of work on I do know some other
people who do work on him and I'm always
interested to find out what they have to
say but he's not somebody who I spend
much much time with oh wow here's a very
tough one this is yeah Heidegger
criticized Hegel as a system builder but
also seems to have admired him could you
discuss your understanding of the
relationship between Heidegger and Hegel
so it's it's not so much that he was a
system builder Heidegger has this notion
that there's what he calls a history of
metaphysics and metaphysics is the study
of being qua being being as such as
literally extends to everything
how do guys take and this is sort of
oversimplifying but got to do that
anyway is that in the history of
metaphysics you have thinkers you know
they're new though they're doing
something interesting and and you know
from Plato all the way to Nietzsche and
Hegel is one of them and they they
produce a new concept of being but what
they do is they take one being and they
use that as sort of the master
hermeneutic to understand all of being
so you know Plato has the forms
Aristotle has substance you know we can
go all the way through
Hegel has this this thing what he calls
spirit and it's connected with history
and Heidegger thinks that this is in
advance you know Heidegger did a course
on Hegel which we have the notes from
unfortunately he only goes up to the
like the you know the self consciousness
section of the phenomenology doesn't do
the rest of it as opposed to like
Nietzsche where he's got you know like
four volumes of lectures on Nietzsche
but anyone had a bigger thinks that
Hegel is sort of advancing things but
he's still remaining within this this
you know overarching history of
metaphysics and so it's still the same
sort of problem over and over again but
you know Heidegger thinks that we can
always draw a lessons from these people
uh martinius what about a new series of
Hegel science of logic in the future
there are some lectures out there on the
science of logic that I think you know
they don't go super far into depth but
they're out there and I you know here's
the thing all of this has to be sort of
financially viable and serious I get I
get a good bit of support for doing that
work but it's it's definitely not the
most popular thing and if you look at
like the number of hours that I put in
on that as opposed to you know what I
would I earn from it and what that means
in terms of like not getting other
projects done
um I don't think that the science of
logic would draw enough to make make
sense to do that and you know before I
talk about it doing another really big
book and doing the half hour Hegel
series approach which is that line by
line thing it's not only gotta be a
question of whether I can you know
actually make it work in terms of
finances and times and stuff like that
it's also do I want to take out another
huge project like that and if I do what
book do I want to do next so I might I
might think more like doing you know
being in time of being in nothingness or
you know like aero-subs metaphysics or
or you know some other some other author
and there are you know I mean there are
people out there who are doing some some
pretty interesting work
Antonia Wolfe I recommend his his site
to those he's a young guy doing a lot of
deep thinking about Hegel I think you
know interesting I I learned by reading
his stuff so I don't know that that I
need to do the science of logic I mean
I'm not I'm not I think Ellie in anyway
I just did the series in part because I
could and nobody else was doing it and I
thought Hegel deserved to have it but I
mean there's there's so many other big
works that would be interesting to do
and I wanted a smaller works you know I
mean I'm gonna do Descartes meditations
like that
Toliver do you think playing video games
are a waste of time I guess it depends
on the video game and it depends on what
you're doing it for it I mean and it
depends on how much time you're spending
like I've had some students who actually
like having to drop out of school
because I got too invested in playing
video games and couldn't get their work
done and failed all their classes there
is a problem right the only video game
that I have played recently has been
minecraft and that's just sort of
[ __ ] around because my like kids like
to play it and so we would get into it a
little bit but I you know I don't get
much trying to do that sort of thing
I'll put it to you this way I play
Minecraft so infrequently that when I
get on sometimes there's new kinds of
or features in the game and I'm like oh
look at that that's yeah I used to like
to really play 4x games like
civilization or masters of variety and
stuff like that
but I haven't even gotten into anything
like that I mean I do play some board
games but generally only when the kids
are here we play Catan and that's a lot
of fun I would love to play diplomacy
online I used to play that but I think
the judge system that they had for that
is long sensitive font but anyway video
games are they waste that's like it
depends on the person right oh here's a
good one from tonight
well I grow a philosopher's beard I
think it actually needs a trim my wife
likes it long like that and I'm not
quite sure why because I think it's
really uncapped but but I guess a lot of
people kind of like it it I'll put it to
this one I'm probably never gonna not
have a beard anymore because I'm used to
not having to shave very often and and
it keeps my face warm and it's kind of
nice and I can't imagine you know mostly
I'm inside getting a wild here I'll
probably always keep my hair pretty long
now that I've grown it back out I didn't
go for it time in my life from you know
part of my graduate school all the way
into I was down in Fayetteville North
Carolina where I kept my head totally
shaved you know but that was that was a
long time ago the thing I don't like
about my beard or just talking about my
wife about this today if so my hair is
mold it's got some white knit and some
gray but it's mostly brown but the beard
is almost all white now you know the
mustache even is some white but is more
Brown so I don't know what the hell
happened with my beard man I'm not gonna
dye it of course or anything like that
not just cuz I'm not vain but I'm also
lazy and I don't want to do upkeep but
you know why did it have to all go gray
there while longer
all right let's see what else we we got
here
Lauren writes I just commenced my first
module in philosophy while I'm at
university got any advice or tips I
would say you know philosophical texts
that if they're worth anything you're
never gonna get everything that's going
on the first or second or third time
that you're reading it they're out
you're always going to be rewarded when
you do multiple readings and you know I
even 20 years later after reading text
you know year after year after year can
be like oh wow look at that
I I missed that and sometimes your
classmates are good at pointing this out
to you or your colleagues to Lana right
I have two favorite teams Dallas and
whoever's playing against the Patriots
yeah that's the way a lot of rivalries
work isn't it now Dallas for me is one
of those teams that growing up here in
70s and 80s
I came to heat and I used to always root
against Dallas but it was actually in
some respect
you know just watching Tony Romo and
stuff like that they kind of won me back
over to like treating them in a neutral
way because Dallas was on fire for a
long time and they were you know
America's team at the time when the
Packers just sucked and there were so
many people here ends and they're always
wearing Dallas gear cuz who wants you
doesn't want to back the winner right
and so I kind of picked up a dislike for
frontalis because of that but now no
it's it's mostly gone I mean who do I do
I reserve my hatred for I mean pretty
much just the Vikings you know for a
long time I didn't like Seattle because
of that bad call years back but stoicism
they actually helped me to like get over
that that kind of stuff as well you know
now here's a good question from Victor
what do you think of Arthur Chopin hours
work tropone R was a really interesting
guy I mean I don't buy his his view but
I love reading him and I was I was
really fortunate in that when I was a
big scholar at European graduate school
you know I was able to take a class with
Schirrmacher who is been me like
president of the International
Schopenhauer Society has written a lot
on Schopenhauer Wolfgang Srilanka and so
he had some you know we read a lot of
Schopenhauer some of which was rereading
for me some of which was new I was I was
the only older person in there for like
you know regular graduate student age in
their 20s was kind of funny because
because a Schirrmacher for for one some
reason or another actually thought that
I was a chef who wanted to study
philosophy but actually the guy who when
I was because my you know my wife it was
also studying there and she's connected
with the Culinary Institute of America
so I guess he thought I was a chef but
we had some great conversations really
enjoyed it he has an interesting theory
about a difference between a grey
Schirrmacher and a white shirt my great
Schopenhauer a white Schopenhauer and
really interesting stuff so I show up
and over to somebody who I'd liked it
get the time to go back to it and shoot
some stuff on Larry Kyle has a
demographic question well the us one day
be taken over by Mormons and Amish
because of their high birth rates if so
who will win in the end well I mean if
it was between just those two there's
way more latter-day saints in there are
Amish so we see that birth rates tend to
you know taper off III can't picture
we're ever gonna be taken over by either
of those groups let's see here
Andre do you think philosophy is too
focused on the theory of other
philosophers and not on the act of
approaching philosophical problems
shouldn't we have more tools on how to
think wine apples I think that's a I see
a lot of people saying that sort of
thing that's great but you do have to
actually learn what other people have
said so you're not reinventing the wheel
as we see so many people doing and you
know not getting as far as you could I
mean why wouldn't you want to be
involved in a conversation now it can be
done a very very you know hey right and
this is one of the problems I think that
we sometimes see with like European
education which more focused on the
history of philosophy and sometimes that
happens in South America too but I think
you know like American students are
actually starving for getting to have
real contact with actual texts rather
than just being given tools or so let's
do philosophy I think we need a balance
of both right Virginia's yes what about
a series I'm sure open hours works yeah
I can see doing that - rates what are
your thoughts on the common distinction
between emotional and rational that's a
good question is that rational is one of
those terms that you know people throw
around a lot
same as logical scientific it's based in
some sort of emotion you know there's a
warm fuzzy glow to rational rationality
and activity which includes the emotions
are bound up together and and I think we
have to take account of that and I think
that's part of what attracts me to a lot
of these thinkers that I'm interested in
like Aristotle or Plato or the Stoics
right because they they examine how
these things are in fact connected so
that's you know that's important ah
canal do you look at means I do indeed
look at memes sometimes but I it's
mostly in my Twitter stream I think or
in my Google+ and I know I don't really
do a lot of that well here's a great
question okay it a funny there's a lot
of questions here so I may I may stay on
a little bit longer even though I get
I'm gonna scroll up just updated here
the here's from Bob the credibility of
philosophers is kind of diminishing
among the public do you think that's
because they don't didn't take it more
of a scientific approach to philosophy
and
the way everyone believes science no I
think the credibility of philosophy is
not diminishing among the public I think
it's already at the low that it's been
at for decades and decades and decades
and I think one of the biggest problems
was that a couple of previous
generations of philosophers primarily in
the analytic tradition but also in the
continental tradition screwed the rest
of us over when times were you know
flush with money by saying we don't need
to make philosophy like you know
practical or reach out to the ordinary
person this isn't for you there's an
elite thing you know youyou can't really
understand it this is you know you see
this a lot in the 70s in the 80s and you
know that works great when there's lots
and lots the money for education and
when there's not a lot of money for it
then if that's your attitude don't be
surprised when everybody else is like
why are we spending money on this crap
you know
let's close the department so let's see
let's see if I can answer this from
jnanis a rather technical question would
you say that the whole box claim that
one cannot control their will can be
read as a reply to compatibilism I mean
doesn't a compatibilist already
recognize that as a feature of
determinism but nonetheless suggest a
different weaker and the aspect notion
of freedom I mean actually read the
whole box so I can't really comment on
that part but you can't control your
will be what can appear red as a reply
to compatible as I'm sure I guess
because a compatible list we can control
our will at least to some degree right
the will is reflexive so yeah oh here's
the thing about super chat other
youtubers who use super chat end up only
answering super chat questions very slow
no selectivity and and and you know
favoring
since ahead of other persons made of
clay how do I read Kierkegaard and not
get confused by his Christian
terminology like soon
that's an easy one don't get confused by
it you know there's lots of Christian
terminology running throughout
philosophy there's nothing that says you
have to get confused about it try to
figure out what Christians mean by it I
mean if you were gonna read Buddhist
philosophy wouldn't you want to know
what they think by terms like emptiness
you know oh you know figure out well
it's what Christians thought about it or
look at what Creek a guard himself has
to say he provides you with some nice
explanations I mean if you're going to
reap your to guard you're gonna intro
that sort of stuff right to here oh
polymer do you believe in academics and
intellectuals have failed our society
where are the all the educated well-read
people of too afraid to speak out why
are all the educated wanted people too
afraid to speak up have academics and
intellectuals fail our society for the
most part yes philosophy is really bad
in that respect most academic
philosophers solves is like hip and
having stuff to say because they chat
with their students once it'll do almost
no outreach whatsoever I can't tell you
how many times I've proposed to people
that they shoot videos and offer them on
YouTube and I get a few colleagues a few
who have done it I don't know who's
actually done it well and that is
Christopher Annandale
about I think it's a Mount Mary
University or Mount Saint Mary
University yeah I mean holes are kind of
timid to begin with it in general well
that's probably enough about that
Christian Chomsky verses Foucault who
won the public because I got to see what
they thought about it right are the
Braxtons Socrates proclaim know thyself
get at the end of his life
he admitted the only thing he knew is
that he knew nothing not even itself no
that's not the only thing they eat said
he said lots and lots of stuff as a
matter of fact at the end of his life he
carried out a very interesting
discussion recording the Phaedo about
all sorts of things that he knew
including the doctrine of recollection
and the nature of courage and all that
so that's that's kind of a non-starter
all right from Scott
I love these open forums thanks doc even
though I'm a Bears fan
anything that's on the stranger vikmo
who has arguments let's start yeah
here's that here's a really important
play the stranger only represents one
way for a person to be and you want to
read it along with the mythos if Isis I
hope I pronounced that right people
always give me a hard time for
mispronouncing it what come move is
saying there
the stranger and mer solo and the
stranger does not stand in for kombu
he's not he's not advocating being like
that and as a matter of fact you know we
have a much more robust camo in novels
like the fall the plague and then the
the book the rebel so that that's that's
important there are like what are the
strongest critiques of Heidegger which
critics of Heidegger should I read a
brief outline of what in Heidegger's
philosophy do you disagree with so
there's lots of critics of Heidegger I
don't have any about about you know
critics of Heidegger I guess you could
say but what do I disagree with in
Heidegger's philosophy I think so
Heidegger intended to treat value as a
projection onto being and this is where
I think Mark Schaefer had things right
and sort of you know the people
following Schaller like dietrich von
Hildebrand or other phenomenologist
doing similar stuff like gabriella
Marcel and I think Heidegger was
fundamentally wrong that that value is
part of being in sort of infuses being
and we can be mistaken about it
that's simply a human projection onto
being canal not into James Joyce what
Ulysses is the greatest work since
forever
I read it I found it's not only was
Joyce you know I found him so
pretentious I found the people who are
into Joyce or pretentious so you know is
there right I guess we have - do you
think a good moral theory would combine
the natural and the ethical a gas I mean
that's that's such a abstract thing you
know depends on what we mean by the
natural that that's that's not a term
that everybody means the same thing by
first did you read Tom Campbell's my big
toe I didn't so I can't really say
anything about that okay um how do you
read literature in your spare time
have you read Kundra Huxley Hollenbeck
Balzac or flow Barre etc I read I
started reading Kundera didn't really
enjoy it read a bit of Balzac read
Huxley he read some flow bear yeah I
read literature in my spirit time as a
matter of fact that they have a whole
series and as men effect I'll get the
link for this I've been doing a series
for guilty pleasure reading right on I
could let the fiction and we have done
23 lectures the last one was on Boris do
it monthly here in the Milwaukee area in
a place called Brookfield now hosted at
a library and you know I've been reading
and rereading those those works for
quite a while uh here we go Homer oh god
thanks I'm not I'm not the only one who
didn't enjoy Joyce I thought I just
wasn't smart enough ha ha I mean yeah I
mean that's the way with a lot of
authors I mean my wife when when we we
were just engaged used to joke around
me did you read this if you read this
have you read this and after a certain
point I was like listen if it's not
speculative fiction and it's after 1950
the answer is probably no you know cuz
she was talking about all this cutting
edge you know New York Times best seller
stuff and I mean best seller or not in
the sense of like you know popular
reading but like high art and a lot of
that stuff you know there's nothing that
says that we have to take these these
authors that are viewed as like the
Canon and say oh they're so wonderful I
I respond to them let's be genuine about
it you know Proust isn't for everybody
choice isn't for everybody
but not for me you know I I love reading
and rag'd you know a lot of people don't
aren't into him you know so you know we
don't all have to like like the same
thing I'd say argue what are your views
on God well you know I am sort of a
reconverted because I left the church a
long time ago but still you know not
very practicing Catholic I think you
know there is a God and I'm not on great
terms with them mostly because of you
know my own issues and I think that you
know religion is something that that's
that's very I used to teach a lot of
comparative religion classes so I did a
lot of research about different
religious systems and beliefs and all
that and do a lot of interaction and
dialogue with people and definitely a
very important dimension of human
existence and not to be totally
discounted or wished away but certainly
subject to lots and lots of things going
going off the rails as well it should
not become a famous philosopher while
he's alive why is it only after a time
that he died that he became famous as a
philosopher well he was kind of before
his time and then there weren't that
many people reading his stuff the birth
of tragedy got mixed reviews drawing a
lot of
he was being lectured on in in Denmark
by Georg Brandes
who's the person who connect you know
sort of connected him up with Dostoevsky
works somebody I wanna just more like
reading of by the way is broad days but
you know that that's that's that's been
the fate of quite a few people and say
why didn't you answer my goddamn phone
are we done here you know
I have no idea okay
Michael how do you know there's such a
thing as free will if Adams things were
made up don't have free will how do we
have free well I mean there's all sorts
of possible answers that maybe it's an
emergent property you know how do you
know you had free will sizing any of it
when you're doing things as though you
have an experience but do you actually
have experiences of being able to choose
this is one that I think it's pretty
easy to get through all right to be
familiar with moogly gondolas work on
the history of Indian philosophy what do
you think of the parallel development of
philosophy in India and Greece I'm not
familiar with that work although I I do
I don't do videos on it but but I do you
know studying something in Indian
philosophy not least because I do some
tutorial prep for people studying for
the Indian Civil Service examination
which requires you to study the history
of philosophy if you're going to take
that optional subject you know so
comparative philosophy that's really the
question can we draw comparisons between
things going on in the you know Greek
Roman world and then later you know
Europe and what's going on in the Indian
cultural sphere yes in parallels there's
not a lot of influence back and forth
from each other we can also say
something similar to the Chinese
cultural sphere and we can say something
similar about things going on in Islamic
philosophy which is more closely tied
I'd say to the to the West
so yeah that's probably enough about
about that canal do you read gee Jack
occasionally when I find that the time
you know mostly these days it's more
reading things that he's writing about
in like op-ed pieces Bob Tom I just got
the book after virtue McIntyre is a
really interesting guy don't stop with
after virtue because it's part of a
series followed by whose justice which
rationality three versions of moral
inquiry rational dependent animals all
the way through to the newest McIntyre
book which I don't have yet
and he's continually developing the the
sort of narrative that he's he's got
working on all right let's do we got
here Oh Johanna writes I enjoyed Julia
honest yep you mentioned her the
intelligent virtue book especially yeah
I really like it too and I was I was
really privileged I got to meet her at
stoic on 2016 because she was one of the
the speakers and I was you know doing a
workshop and and so Massimo Pigliucci
hosted a dinner the night before for all
of the speakers to get to you know hang
out and stuff like that so I got to chat
with her a little bit I was a little
star-struck you know because it's sort
of like being an amateur or musician and
getting to like go backstage with with
people who's like stuff you've been
listening to for years and maybe even
like you know playing in your own time
I'm not doing that doing as well by
getting to meet one of your one of your
one of your or would you call it one of
your heroes one of your I've been
fortunate that I've got to meet like
that I'll mention Chris Gill to you know
he these people tend to be very
down-to-earth to a very personable but
you know you you feel kind of funny
you're talking to I got to interact with
Alastair McIntyre's and the faculty some
with him you know one one summer at
notre-dame and then we cross paths at
conferences Paul Griffiths yeah there's
been quite a few people like that
Kate Rodgers in an some studies you know
so yeah it's kind of cool here I'm and
why is there month not much interest in
Middle Eastern philosophy there's not
much interest in American in
anglo-american philosophy and most
philosophers not a hell of a lot of
interest in plate because the analytic
philosophy Canon dominates and where
analytic philosophy isn't dominating
it's usually continental philosophy
that's dominating your radical
philosophy right there's not a lot of
space for history philosophy I will
mention and pointing you know westward
that at Marquette they have the Aquinas
and the Arabs project started by by
Taylor right and they are studying you
know Arabic and other languages they're
reading you know even Xena and I've
arose and and all Farabi and discussing
them and if you if you come to Marquette
and you go to the Aristotle conference
in the summer you're also gonna see some
stuff it's these Islamic thinkers as
well so this is one place this is really
funny Ben Ben keeps asking is this live
yeah it's live I'm I mean I'm talking
right now not quite sure what that's
about
okay now philosophy is mental
masturbation than my reading of Hegel
some weird sadomasochism yeah now you
want some real state of masochism in
that way read lakhan's a Creek right
Lacan is an interesting thinker talking
about Jacques Lacan the psychoanalytic
guy who brings together Hagel and
structuralism and Freud and all that
his seminars are pretty straightforward
and easy to read is a career like
deliberately no crazy and off the wall
as possible and and they're much harder
to make things out of all right let's
see scrolling down a bit ah I'm gonna
take one from Alejandro cuz I'm gonna
start drawing things to a close we're
already like bid over time you probably
get this question a lot but how do I
begin studying philosophy by myself
specially ethics and politics read some
things in your playlist but would love
some further advice so you know if it's
I thinks in politics you know it's good
good thing to do is to just start with
Plato and start you know moving on
through that and you can so you can do
it historically or you can decide to
listen I I know that there's a bunch of
different moral theories out there
why don't I focus in on some of them so
you could start with utilitarianism
start with dant illogical thinkers it's
a bit more complicated but you know how
do you begin studying it by yourself so
you know get the texts you know what to
buy them you could get them sometimes at
the library or a lot of them are online
and you know read through them and try
to think about what what sort of general
ideas is this guy or you know in the
case of some female authors a girl
putting out there and how do they fit
together and and don't expect it all to
like you know really the other thing to
keep in mind is that these thinkers are
in in conversation with each other
sometimes you know mistakenly sometimes
tendentious Lee but they're they're
connected with each other right you know
you you know the picture will slowly
emerge over time and you don't have to
worry
this is another thing I should actually
do a video about this you don't have to
worry about like having all the right
people because nobody reads everything
in the history of philosophy it's
impossible to do that
there's just too much stuff at this
point in time right even with like
people who are like they claim to be you
know students of such-and-such they
haven't usually read all of their books
it's enough to like fine central things
and and see what what you know you
actually respond to and and sort of work
your way through it and rights Peterson
is a good freedom of speech guy is an
atheist promoting Christian values which
is an interesting contradiction yeah you
know I it depends on what Christian
values are being promoted you see this
with like recently with like you know
Bannen looks a lot like Charles Marat of
accion France says you know the the turn
of the 20th century in France promote
you know Christian values meaning like
the last or whatever you want but I was
gonna ask well who's Christianity are we
talking about right and there's plenty
of Christians that that are open to
atheists and plenty of atheists that are
open to Christians so that that's great
and yeah I guess Peterson is promoting
freedom of speech good we do need that
but you know it's rather to densha so I
don't see him promoting even like across
the board and worked up over you know
anybody who he thinks is attacking it as
far as I can tell so all right let me
skip down a bit there's a lot of chitter
chatter about Peterson here animal
rights
I literally just discovered a channel a
few hours are know looking up
information on Hegel my question is what
reading do you think is necessary to
begin reading being in time
well I wouldn't jump right into being in
time you know unless you've got kind of
a good background in the history of
philosophy it can't hurt to read some
poster all Heidegger is also kind of
indebted to sailors he points out
um Heidegger is kind of tough I would
actually before reading being in time I
might read some shorter pieces by
Heidegger you know there's that nice
Heidegger basic work so it's got a bunch
of his essays in there yeah that's a
tough one being in time is a-- is a
tough one what happens when a definition
of external success doesn't fulfill you
then you move on to thinking about what
is fulfilling i think that's kind of
point for a lot of people you know
there's what leads to midlife crises
right way often make well that person's
going through a midlife crises oh you
know midlife crisis is really an
opportunity for for philosophical you
know approach to what is a person and
what what makes us satisfies what are
what are real goods I think you know
midlife crises they suck but they're
great opportunities for people to adopt
you know resources from philosophy and
then you know maybe move towards
happiness alright a random guy why do
you think Nietzsche is considered by
laymen to be analysts because a lot of
other people have called them analysts
and they don't they don't check out it I
mean it's the same thing with any sort
of narrative this is why you don't want
to trust you know sort of you know
textbooks on philosophy because some of
them are great and some of them are sort
of like trusting translations unless you
can actually read the original you don't
know the translation is is very good
good good question from still good any
tips for stem students on starting in
philosophy yeah to begin with don't
expect what you're studying in
philosophy to be like what you've been
studying in your stem
asses you know linger with it and see
see where it's going donuts you know
clear answers and then start thinking at
once you actually get get your your head
wrapped around a particular thinker
don't worry so much about are they right
or are they wrong start thinking about
alright so I've got you know what
Aristotle says about this down that I've
learned in my stem classes and see
whether there's any way in which there
could be a connection between these the
same thing I would say by the way for
people they're like business management
you know you know just as adopting a
teleological perspective inform how I
understand positions you know that
things like that are really quite quite
useful I think here's a good question
from Ravi if humerus caused by
incongruity why do people laugh the
second time a joke is told well maybe
it's not caused just by incongruity
maybe we need a more complex theory of
humor or it could be because it's still
funny you know that's that's the case
the we only got a few minutes left
before I got to actually get to
something scroll all the way down and
see what we've got that I could very
quickly knock out I'm not gonna get to
everybody's questions but you know
really right and then then you're gonna
be in it earlier a lot of questions on a
lot of different things
oh yeah so here's here's a good one from
Alexandre could you share anything that
we might not know about Cicero I'm a
huge fan of Cicero and I'm actually
gonna be doing a video hopefully later
this month about why I'm a big fan of
Cicero and next month I'm doing the
first of the
third quarterly series on philosophers
in the midst of history at the Frank
Weinberg library here locally talking
about Cicero as well I really admire
Cicero as a a practical philosopher
somebody who had you know certainly a
big day job and was very involved in
Roman politics and also in Roman culture
he was a guy who saw a genuine need to
inform Roman culture carried out in you
know latin by bringing in greek
philosophy into it and he he you know
engaged in this process not just of
essentially translating but
reinterpreting greek philosophy in a lat
idiom and he did so because people were
saying you know there's a plan the
language doesn't admit of it and he's
like no you can do philosophy and land
you you people being pretentious you
know saying you can only do it in greek
I'm going to show you that it could be
done and he did dismiss Cicero you know
I'd say in the 19th century and in the
20th century and they said well his work
is just derivative but I think that was
the wrong perspective to take what you
know we worry about originality way too
much and what I think we got to focus on
more is how are you reinterpreting this
stuff in a way that you know brings out
the key ideas and gets it across to
people and allows us to apply it to our
own place the other thing I'll say about
Cicero that I really like he is a person
who really loves the life of the mind
but he criticizes other philosophers for
not being engaged enough in actual life
and he says this even about Plato though
I'm the older I get the more I'm
attracted to that that sort of notion so
that that's probably enough about Cicero
it's already 2:30 here I was gonna stop
that too but
but we went on a bit longer I didn't get
to everybody's questions so I'm sorry
for those that I didn't get to that one
more reason we want to get here early
and get your question up there in the
queue I don't know that I can get to
everything so do these AMAs every month
you know I post them on my Facebook page
you can go to reason i/o and see the
calendar as well I don't know what else
to say about that they're all I'm also
in Goodreads and I'll put them in
Goodreads as well great questions and I
hope all of you have the evening or
morning wherever you happen to be and so
I'm just gonna sign off and that's that